serious determined but silent the
Northern Ireland secretary not giving
anything away on the latest preparations
for brexit or knocked over the 31st he
was one of many ministers to have left
the daily Whitehall meetings discussing
how to insulate the UK from the fallout
from an Odile brexit movie ever more
likely if the current standoff continues
we're leaving on the 31st ideally with a
deal a better deal but if not we're
leaving anyway the more resolute Boris
Johnson's team sound the more intense
the efforts to stop him shaping up for a
titanic clash this autumn between MPs
and the government the question is one
of decisions that are normally made over
here end up with both sides reaching for
lawyers and end up having to be
adjudicated over here at the Supreme
Court Sky News understands that both
sides have been talking to lawyers the
question that judges might have to
decide is if the Johnson government and
MPs remain fundamentally at loggerheads
which side has the final say there are
two main ways for MPs to stop a no deal
brexit the first to use the fixed term
Parliament act to bring down the
government via a vote of no-confidence
and force an election if they get a
majority of MPs to say they don't have
confidence then they have 14 days to
find an alternative that does have one
which could include a cross party
national unity government if there's a
preferred successor then there is at
this mechanism in the act that
confidence can be voted within 14 days
in an alternative government it's not
quite clear where that alternative
government comes from and that's where I
think MPs need to be quite canny they
will need to express their view very
clearly to the Queen
the second option they have to stop an
ideal would be to pass legislation to
tie Boris Johnson's hands to force him
to seek an extension any legislation
that is passed is absolutely binding on
the government you know the government
is there to enact the decisions of
Parliament there's no doubt about that
it would be challenging within the
timescale to get that done
there are many bridges to cross before
opponents can be confident of stopping a
No Deal brexit jeremy corbyn's allies
say they won't support a government
of national unity but we'll work with
political rivals in other ways there are
a number of parliamentary tactics that
we'll be seeking to use to avoid a No
Deal brexit ranging from working on a
cross-party basis all the way through to
tactical work what not to disclose today
Boris Johnson tonight seems to be
sitting pretty he and the other mug in
his life Jacob Riis MOG seem
increasingly likely to deliver No Deal
brexit opponents are divided on tactics
strategy and broader goals they need to
find all three and fast to seize back
the initiative Sam code Sky News